la question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre entre Paris et Berlin
rien ne va plus le Conseil des ministres
franco-allemand normalement prévu demain
vient d'être reporté cinédié suite à des
divergences importantes entre nos deux
pays les contentieux sont désormais
nombreux l'Allemagne bloque deux
importants projets industriels en
matière de défense le projet d'avion et
le projet de char l'Allemagne verrouille
au niveau européen le contrôle des
exportations d'armement l'Allemagne
vient de choisir un bouclier antimicile
qui tourne le dos à la France
l'Allemagne vient d'investir seul 200
milliards d'euros pour ces entreprises
et ses ménages pour faire face au prix
de l'énergie et nous dit que si nous
avions été budgétairement plus vertueux
nous pourrions faire de même l'Allemagne
refuse également la modification du mode
de calcul du prix de l'énergie à
l'échelle européenne qui pourtant serait
tellement importante pour la France
madame la Première ministre vous vous
contentez de parler de souveraineté là
où le chancelier Scholl s’exerce que
comptez-vous faire désormais pour
défendre les intérêts de la France je
vous remercie
je vous remercie
[Musique]